i'm interested in
positive social impact i'm interested in
how we can deploy
innovation to bring more opportunity to
people across
the planet i'm interested in connecting
the unconnected we live in a world of
globalization we live in a world where
we are increasingly tethered
together by cellular broadband networks
we live in a world where connectivity is
non-negotiable at the same time
too many people billions across the
planet are still
not connected this is a problem that
requires
a transformation and innovation that
requires new infrastructure that we
don't yet
have only about 10 of the surface of the
planet has
cellular broadband connectivity but my
friends
innovation is here arthur c clarke said
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
enter space mobile space mobile is the
world's
first space-based cellular broadband
network a company that is about to
deploy a fleet of
satellites that will allow existing
hardware existing
cell phones to connect to a space-based
cellular broadband network we're talking
low latency broadband
speeds whenever you're out of
traditional cellular
coverage think about what becomes
possible we are truly talking about
connecting
the unconnected we are talking about
positively impacting a billion
lives we are talking about wiring us
together to participate in the global
marketplace of ideas
of conversation and of commerce what
will happen
is the more than five billion
smartphones that constantly move in and
out of
coverage you'll get a notification when
you're out of coverage asking you if you
want to connect to space
mobile again the world's first
space-based cellular broadband network
and by simply answering yes
on that text message you'll be
immediately connected again
to broadband speeds broadband access the
kind of innovation that cloaks the
planets and connectivity
truly one-of-a-kind enterprise and one
that i can get behind
companies that will change the world
certainly space mobile
is one of those companies
you